[Music]
hello there June is here once again and
with it comes a bunch of games wanting
your time like usual I found a range of
titles from Triple A Behemoth to reduced
price classic and a handful of
free-to-play titles that have finally
released so let's not wait around let's
do this
there's three massive games dropping
this month Final Fantasy 16 is the one
for the PlayStation Gamers as it's only
releasing on PS5 initially at least
don't worry you don't need to know what
happened in the other 15 Mainline Final
Fantasy games as the stories are unique
with some reoccurring elements like huge
summons and big chickens called chocobos
this time the action RPG takes us to a
medieval inspired World filled with
castles and kingdoms we play as Clive
who is the guardian of little brother
Joshua who has the ability to summon a
huge icon if his kingdom is ever in need
the thing is other nations also have a
ward who can summon an icon and peace in
this land cannot last forever combat is
a blend of melee combos dodging and
ranged magic attacks as Clive embarks on
a tale of Vengeance that will span a
lifetime I was lucky enough to play
Final Fantasy 16 last month and I've got
to admit I'm looking forward to seeing
the story through Final Fantasy 16
releases exclusively on PS5 on June 22nd
[Music]
next street fighter returned with a big
number six after its name capcom's
iconic fighting game has received an
impressive visual overhaul as well as
updates to game modes at its core Street
Fighter 6 remains a one-on-one fighter
which is easy to learn but impossible to
master and losing makes people very
angry to alleviate that the controls
have been revamped it's possible to play
in a new modern style where a single
button press replaces a once complicated
move I'm not too sure how I feel about
that the world tour game mode adds a
single player variation more like an
action game to be honest after creating
a custom character and oh my gosh I've
seen some custom characters we go out
into the world and pick fights like a
bully along the way we learn and train
with iconic Street Fighter characters
like Kami and Chun Li Metro city is
almost like a fighting RPG made for
people who don't enjoy competitive
Brawlers graphically Fighters will now
be visually hurt with ripped clothes or
bruises or cuts to add to the realism
and a bunch of mini games and training
modes are included too Street Fighter 6
could be amazing look out for it on June
2nd on PS4 PS5 the Xbox series and PC
the Juggernaut that is Diablo 4 releases
on June 6th it's a hack and slash
dungeon crawling action RPG I'm not
really into these games so I asked a few
hardcore players why they love it so
much and they always say the same thing
it's about mastering the skill and loot
system understanding what all the
numbers do and managing the Buffs the
status effects and the cooldowns is the
core gameplay with seemingly Limitless
ways to respeck a character to change
entire playthroughs and then there are
other random elements like finding a
pair of boots with extra Dodge rolls or
a hat that lets you spam attacks quicker
Diablo is definitely for a certain type
of player the dark storytelling is said
to be the most improved as Lilith has
been resurrected and the Lord of hatred
forces mankind to descend into madness
expect to see a lot of Diablo 4 online
for a long time as there will be a live
service with the game constantly
updating and upgrading if that's your
thing grab Diablo 4 on June 6th on the
PlayStations the Xboxes and the PC
it's been a very long time since the WWE
games had a real competitor well we
finally found one aew fight forever
releases this month a wrestling game
developed by ux who arguably made the
best WWE games before their relationship
broke down there are nine match types at
launch ranging from simple singles
matches to full-on exploding barbed wire
death matches the headliners include CM
Punk Chris Jericho and Kenny Omega
personally I'm looking forward to
something a little different from the
usual WWE product June 29th is game time
on PS4 PS5 the Xboxes and PC and switch
2.
okay let's have a look at some free
games for this month I intended to go
into depth about blue protocol but like
any game I'm looking forward to it's
been delayed unless you're in Japan the
Western release is now 2024. I'll come
back to it in the future well on the
plus side remember when I told you about
the console release of track Mania
scheduled for February well three months
later it finally released to absolutely
no Fanfare at all it's downloadable
right now the Esports scene around this
game is way more intense than I expected
and to bring more eyes to the game it's
finally free on all platforms with
weekly Nations leagues for those who
want to take their hobby further or just
a race with friends trackmania doesn't
have a great deal to offer but what it
does do it does well especially the
ability to create your own tracks to
challenge other people online another
free-to-play game that totally missed
its initial release date is warlander
and yet again it's now out on PC and
console without any Fanfare the medieval
inspired fantasy Warfare game combines
hack and slash shooting and strategy to
win these 100 person battles Castle CGS
are my preferred game mode as we roll a
huge battering ram towards another
team's Castle to break through their
defenses and take out their core before
the time runs out things get even more
insane when there are five Army versions
of these game modes classes in include
Warriors clerics and even a mage which
can all be customized building a
character unique to your play style
while under is out now on Playstation
Xbox and PC
[Music]
I oh I do have one more free game this
month Paul Blitz on the PS5 a simple but
effective full game that supports
classic 8 ball and 9 ball versions
there's also an interesting battle Blitz
mode where every ball you pot appears on
your opponent's table and everyone they
put appears on yours if you have seven
friends you're able to set up an eight
player tournament online and watch the
games through together and I'm told it's
legal to Heckle your friends Paul Blitz
isn't going to wow you massively but
it's out now on PS5 if you want
something different to do one last
update on the free to play front there's
a chance that honkai star rail will be
releasing on June 7th on Playstation but
alas I wasn't able to get this confirmed
before I made this video last month
honkai star rail launched for free on PC
and mobile to solid reviews and the
PlayStation version was aiming for
update 1.1 to join the fun and update
1.1 is on June 7th so please don't quote
me on this but that could be the release
date for my PS5 brother brothers and
sisters to see if this turn-based RPG is
their kind of gacha game regardless I'll
have a full breakdown next month
okay let's get back to priced games but
reduced priced games retailing at 30. 30
Euros or 25 pounds here in the UK is
Crash team Rumble a four and four
platformer let me explain each level
starts with a free-for-all to pick up as
many Wampa fruit as possible and then
it's a case of getting all that fruit
back home and banking it layer on top of
that fighting mechanics to impact the
opposition and a range of boosts and
Buffs and you've got crash team Rumble
there are also classes for roles in the
team the scorers can hold 121 per fruit
before they have to get back and they
also move a bit quicker boosters can't
hold as many fruit but they can pick up
relics which leads to team boosts and
then there are blockers who are there to
frustrate the opposition although
they're a bit slow Crush team Rumble
releases on June 20th on PS4 PS5 and the
Xboxes Sonic Origins released their year
ago and combined a bunch of Sonic titles
from the early days of the Blue Blur on
June 23rd an updated version will be
released Sonic Origins plus with even
more content like adding Amy into Sonic
1 through to Sonic CD 12 Game Gear
titles have been added and every piece
of post launch content from the last
year is in here too retailing at 40 US
dollars there's a crazy amount of Sonic
the Hedgehog to be played if that's your
jam
and finally another 40 game alien's Dark
Descent a real-time strategy game set in
the alien franchise we'll be tactically
going up against Xenomorphs after crash
landing on a planet full of them imagine
x-com without any time to stop and think
aliens Dark Descent has us managing
health and stress levels of the team in
addition to objectives like clearing a
sector or welding shut potential weak
points and if a squad mate dies they are
gone forever so your decisions matter in
every single Mission aliens Dark Descent
drops on June 20th on PS4 PS5 the Xboxes
and PC so if you're still here and my
voice hasn't gone you deserve a dad joke
what kind of shoes do ninjas wear
sneakers of course give me a sec give me
a sec I can do better than that which
bear is the most condescending a Pandora
it's been a pleasure I'll see you next
time
[Music]